- [Narrator] This UCSD-TV program
is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn? Visit our website
or follow us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large-brained.
Long the master of fire, tools,
and language, but still trying to
understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism. We grow up
slowly. We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive. We
shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Christopher] I'm gonna start
with a family photo.
This is my niece, Allison.
She's about seven years old.
And this is also my niece, Allison,
right after birth.
So what's going on here? There's something
very unusual about our species, right?
We take it for granted that our newborns
come out with a very large amount of
body fat under the skin, or subcutaneous
fat. We even have a name for it; baby fat,
and we consider it a mark of health.
But this is actually a very unusual
characteristic. If you look across other
species, like gorilla for instance,
they come out skinny.
Here's a baboon, also very skinny.
Almost twenty years ago, I compiled all
the information I could about body fat
and newborns, and published a paper
on it. And this is what I found.
These species here, as you can see,
are all about 3% body fat or less
at birth. And this includes species
like elephant, seals, black bear,
pigs, so typical mammals. Over here
you have harp seals, guinea pigs, and
the very fattest species that I could find
evidence for was us, at about 15%
body fat. Now preparing for this talk, I
went into the literature and tried to find
any more data points that had been
published, especially on primates. Notice
here that the only primate that I could
find was a baboon, at about 3%. We
have some more data points now. We have
macaques, squirrel monkeys, another
species of macaques all have less than
3%. Over here on the left you will
see that there is a new species that I
found that is actually a little bit fatter
than us, it seems. But there are only 2
individuals in that sample and they are
clinical. They are a clinical sample, not
a wild sample. We will see how that shakes
out, but it really does not fundamentally
change the story. It is pretty clear that
this is an unusual characteristic for us.
We are born with a lot of body fat and not
only that... Look at body fat development
post-natally. What this shows is skinfold
thickness. This is how you measure the
thickness of the subcutaneous fat. You
take a skinfold and you literally
measure it with a caliper.
This is the average here, this red line,
within the population. You see that we are
born with a lot of fat, but then right
after birth we put lots of calories into
putting on more fat. Our fat actually
peaks out during the first year of life.
And then it declines until that very low
point that I showed you earlier, in mid
childhood. The question that I want to
pose today is, why are our newborns so
unusually fat and yet our children are so
lean? Before getting into this, I want to
dispel one myth that you will find out
there. If you look at old pediatrics
text books, there is this idea that yes,
this is an unusual characteristic for our
species. Perhaps it is insulation because
we lost hair. We lost our hair and we need
this insulatory layer of blubber to
compensate for that. There is a lot of
evidence against that. Sounds like a neat
idea, but we don't have any evidence that
humans preferentially deposit fat under
the skin. What happens is the more fat you
put on the more fat you get under the
skin. It is a good place to put it. There
is nothing that suggests that we have
anatomically adapted ourselves for that
kind of insulatory layer.
There are human populations that live in
the high Arctic, places like Alaska and so
forth, where you see biological
adaptations to conserve heat. You see
shorter limbs and you see shorter stature.
What this does is it reduces skin surface
area and reduces heat loss. In this
populations you see no evidence for
thicker skin folds, in fact they tend to
have slightly thinner skinfolds than
the temperate populations. Finally, you
can look at newborns and see studies that
have done this to try to figure out what
it is that predicts thermal stability.
It is not the skinfold thicknesses that
matter. It seems to be the muscle mass,
which is where the heat's being generated.
I didn't find a lot of evidence to support
this idea that this excessive amount of
subcutaneous fat, especially in our
newborns, is related to insulation.
So I've proposed a different idea, a
competing idea. The key to understanding
our unusually fat babies may lie in an
other unique human trait, our unusually
large and energetically costly brains. The
idea here is that if you have a large and
energetically costly brain, you're gonna
need, effectively, a bigger battery to
back it up during a period of shortage.
That's the idea I want to dig into today.
We're gonna explore, we're gonna talk a
bit about the human brain, it's energetic
costs, and why we need a bigger energy
backup. Then I'm gonna tell you about some
new work that some collaborators and I
published last year that quantifies the
cost of the brain across the life cycle,
from birth onward. Finally, we're gonna
bring all this together with some other
information and try to make sense of this
pattern of fat development that
we see in humans.
Let's start with this first point. We're
a brainy species. The last four million
years, as you see here, you see a lot of
increase in brain size. As I've already
alluded to, this is important
energetically because brain is costly
tissue. A gram of adult brain uses about
fifteen times the energy of a gram of
muscle. All of you sitting here right now
are adults, your body is putting off heat
at about a hundred watts. That's the
amount of heat you're generating, warming
up the room. Twenty of those watts or 20%
of your resting metabolic rate is
accounted for by the brain. That may not
seem that impressive. It may even seem a
little dim, but if you compare us to other
species, you'll see that that's actually
pretty remarkable. All these species up
here are in the order of 2 to 3% of
resting metabolic rate goes to the brain.
Here you see there's a couple primate
species, spider monkeys and chimpanzees,
at about 10%, and then human adults
are at 20%. If you look at a newborn
of course, the size of the head is
so much larger compared to the body, so
that number is gonna be a lot bigger in
the newborn. Sure enough, in the old
literature, the estimate had been that 60%
of the resting metabolism is
necessary just to keep the brain going.
This is important. It's not only just
costly, but it has other ramifications,
because unlike other tissues and organs
you can't turn the brain down. You can't
dim it. Let's say that you're starving or
under nutritional stress, the brain has a
constant metallic rate whether you're
sleeping, active, what have you. It has to
be maintained. Without access to that
energy you get brain damage. Naturally, it
makes sense that we need to have a bigger
energy backup. You can think of an
analogy from day to day life that
I think illustrates this. That would be
a mortgage. Every month, if you have a
house and you have a house mortgage, you
have to pay that mortgage. If you don't
you have to foreclose. If you lose your
job, you'd better have money in your
savings account in order to cover that
mortgage for the period you are
unemployed. The bigger your mortgage, the
bigger the savings account you're gonna
need to have to avoid a foreclosure. It's
the same sort of logic. Effectively, our
newborns have a mortgage that accounts for
60% of their budget, so they need
to have a very big savings account. Maybe
this gives us some insights into what's
going on at birth, but we also have to
understand why we become so lean by
childhood. We set up both of this
problems. Maybe it's the change in the
size of that mortgage that matters. Let's
go ahead and start to look at that. What
this shows here is the percentage of body
weight that's accounted for by the brain
at different ages in humans. At birth, as
you can see, it's about 12% of body
weight. Then it declines as that ratio of
brain size to body size also declines.
Perhaps we need this big energy buffer
back here because our brains really
dominate the budget, but down here less
so. Maybe that's what's going on.
Unfortunately, it's not that simple
because all we're looking at in that last
graph is the size of the brain. There are
other factors to take into account. Energy
used by a gram of brain is actually very
dynamic very development and this relates
to the high cost of learning during
childhood. What makes the brain costly is
synapses, that is, the connections between
nerves. The number of synapses changes
very dramatically. Let's take a look at
that. These are classic data on synaptic
densities. This is telling us how many
synapses there are, how many neural
connections there are within a gram of
brain. You can see that it goes way up
quickly after birth, peaks out during
childhood, and then it declines again.
There's a process of pruning. This entire
period of very high synaptic connectivity
is all about learning during childhood.
What it means from our perspective is
that there's a need for energy to buoy
that excess neuronal activity. So how does
one go about measuring that energy? Well,
positron emission tomography imaging, PET
imaging, is one way you could do this.
This is what allows you to measure the
rate of glucose uptake in the brain.
Harry Chugani, in a classic paper from
1987 that I'm showing here, did this in
kids from birth all the way up to
adulthood. You can see these folks over
here on the right, are the adults. So this
dotted line is the adult level of glucose
uptake. At birth, each gram of brain
tissue is using about 30% less glucose
than the adult brain. That's because the
synapses haven't proliferated yet. Then by
childhood, it's actually twice the adult
rate, so it's much higher. Then you get
the pruning and it prunes down to the
adult level eventually. What we need to
really take into account what's going on
with the brain, is not just to account for
the size of the brain. But we also need to
take into account this changing energy
density, this changing energy use rate
related to learning. This is actually
something that I and my collaborators in
Northwestern University, at Wayne State,
and at George Washington University set
out to do. We published a paper on this
last year. I'm going to tell you what we
did, very quickly. We started with
Chugani's pet data, which I've already
shown you. That tells us how much glucose
each gram of brain is using. To get the
global cost of the brain, we need to know
how many grams of brain there are. For
that, we used brain volume data from MRI.
You do the numbers and you get total brain
energy cost. There are many more steps
involved, but that's a simplified version.
When you do that, this is what we find.
This shows brain glucose uptake from birth
until 15 years of age. Fifteen years is
the last PET measurements, that's where
we stopped. You can see that it peaks out
at about 5 years of age.
It's higher in males
because they're just bigger.
There's no real biological
difference there. There's a remarkable
story here. Brain glucose uptake at
5 years of age is about twice the adult
level. You can see this dotted line here.
Their brains are using twice the energy of
the adult brain, despite the fact that
their brains haven't fully reached adult
size yet, and despite the fact that their
bodies are one-third the size. This is a
remarkable burden on their bodies,
energetically. That's what we want to take
into account. Let's look at the next step
here. Instead of looking at grams of
glucose, let's consider brain energetics
as a fraction of the resting metabolic
rate, like we did earlier. When we do it
that way, we see that it's peaking out
at about 4 to 5 years of age again. And at
that point, two-thirds of all resting
calories are going to the brain,
which is pretty remarkable.
This leaves only one-third of the calories
to do everything else.
So clearly, some other functions
must have been short-changed in us.
One of those functions that did get
short-changed, it looks like, was body
weight growth. What this shows here is the
rate of body weight gain. As we all know,
infants grow very quickly, and then the
rate of weight gain slows down. They start
to grow quite slowly by age 5 or so,
or during childhood. You almost don't see
them growing. You notice their development
but you don't see them getting bigger and
bigger. Then, gradually, weight gain takes
off again with puberty. Let's superimpose
the brain energetics curve on that.
There's pretty clearly a nice relationship
between these two. As the brain becomes
increasingly costly, because of
brain growth and the proliferation of
those costly synapses, body weight growth
is going down. When the brain is at its
most costly, body weight growth is at
its lowest. And then it reverses
with puberty.
So clearly, there is something very
interesting going on here. It looks like
one of the ways that we were able to
support these very high energetic costs
related to brain development is by
taking calories that would have
gone into growth and
putting them into the brain.
So we're kind of subsidizing that.
One of the things that suffers from that
is fat stores. That's why we have such low
adiposity during this era, because
we're basically shutting down growth
and we're shutting down fat deposition.
This leads to a bit of a paradox in what
would appear to be a challenge for a
hypothesis. We've got the age of lowest
energy reserves, when our savings account
is at its lowest, coinciding with the age
when our mortgage is at its highest. This
looks very precarious. Doesn't this
potentially pose a problem for a
hypothesis? If baby fat is a brain
battery, how can body fat reach its lowest
level at the age when the brain's energy
needs are greatest. The answer is, you
don't necessarily need a large savings
account if you've got wealthy relatives
and friends who are willing to lend to
you. That's what goes on. Let's take a
look at this. As children grow and develop
they shift from relying on their onboard
energy buffer, their body fat, to social
buffering. The effectiveness of social
buffering increases and as that happens,
the reliance on body fat goes down. We're
gonna take a look at this. Let's start
early on, when there's this high reliance
on body fat as we've already talked about.
Why do we rely on body fat early?
The reason is this; because of the
cause of nutritional stress.
Early in life, the main causes of
nutritional stress are infectious disease.
Forget about the common cold. Think about
environments that are less sanitized than
ours. Infections can be quite severe.
This is really the cause of, for instance,
under-5 mortality, infant mortality.
It's all about under nutrition and most of
it is driven by infection. It's easy to
see why. Kids when they get sick, they get
anorexia. They stop eating. Diarrheal
diseases are very common in infancy. This
impairs digestion. Your parents and your
caregivers can have all the calories and
the food in the world, but if you stop
eating and you don't digest, you're not
gonna get access to them. Which forces you
to go internal and rely on your on onboard
energy reserves. That's really the only
strategy that you have. Add on top of
this, fever that actually increases your
energy expenditure and sort of makes the
whole thing worse. That's the point. The
common symptoms related to infections, cut
the baby off from caregivers and force a
reliance internally on their own battery.
Here we see the age trends in diarrheal
illness, globally. And you see that it
really peaks out in late infancy and the
second half of the first year. This
coincides with weaning and the
introductions of foods that are often not
sterile. Newborns are born without
antibodies which is why they get sick so
much. Every time they get sick, they
acquire antibodies and they become more
and more protected moving forward. As
infants age, they acquire these protective
antibodies, and the infections then
plummet. They're really not a problem by
four to five years of age, or not as much.
As those infections go down, they're no
longer being cut off from their caregivers
and they can start to benefit from the
unique features of the way we raise
our kids. I'm gonna talk about that.
It'll be the last point we talk about.
If we look at other mammals, food comes
from the mother, breast milk. Eventually
you get weaned and you self-provision.
In our species, fathers are a part of the
picture, both in terms of provisioning and
care, but there's a whole cast of other
characters. This is something fairly
unique to us. We're considered cooperative
breeding species because many individuals
are involved in raising our kids.
Importantly, those human caregivers, in
turn, are embedded with the networks based
on cooperation and food sharing. Let's
take a look at this. Here's an example
where there are four hunters that are not
sharing. The second individual down has a
kill and the others don't, so they go
hungry. On this day, the first individual
has a kill, but the others go hungry,
and so on.
It's kind of a feast/famine scenario.
Here's the same scenario where this
individual shares with other folks
under the assumption that they're gonna
share with him when they have a kill.
In this kind of system, with food sharing,
everybody gets to eat every day.
You don't have the feast/famine.
This is what we do.
If you look at data from hunter/gatherer
societies like the Hiwi and the Ache
from lowland Amazon in South America,
this shows the number of families
that receive part of the kill.
This is very common.
Food flows between families. Here's an
other interesting study that was done
among the Hadza. Here, the individuals
were given honey sticks. There was an
economic game and the researchers
evaluated how honey flowed through the
society. As you can see, it's flowing all
over the place to both genetic kin, to
in-laws and to friends. If somebody up
here comes up short one day, there's gonna
be food coming from elsewhere. Our
caregivers, there are not only multiple
caregivers taking care of our kids, but
they're embedded in these networks of
cooperation of food sharing which buffer.
It's for this reason, I think, that we
can go out on a limb as children.
Our children go way out on a limb, because
they're maxing out the size of their
mortgage at a point when the have a
minimal savings account. They can do it
because they're embedded within those
networks. To summarize and come back to
where I began, our babies are born with a
lot of fat. The reasons for this are that
they have extremely high energy
requirements for their brains that are
fragile, combined with the fact that the
primary cause of nutritional stress at
this age is infection, which cuts them
off from caregivers and forces a reliance
on internal stores. The situation's very
different by childhood. The brain is even
more costly, but now they're embedded
within, and benefit from that social
buffering that's so effective.
They no longer need to put those calories
away in a savings account. They can use
them for things that matter at this age;
learning and child development.
That's all. Thanks.
♪ [music] ♪